[Music]
[Laughter]
we have to outsmart them with portals
[Music]
what is my I call you Maya my church
bruh I think you shot another part of
like way back here
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh you don't care about my family out
where do they go
stop going in that bag
wait million you can movie
well it's gonna take us a while my god
you will never be able to thank in we
played on your analyzer oh yeah we're
gonna it's safe to go come in come in no
take out the bathroom take it oh my shoe
I get my thing for you you take its I'm
actually out of life no no don't touch
that night do not have to get all right
yo
right over here but oh I forgot one
thing
right right wait you have to jump from
here okay let's do another matter okay
because we were pretty terrible at sea
or not
whoa whoa whoa well I think we have a
maximum time here so we don't have to
worry about it
cause he's not being smart because
opposed those things needs to be up
there you think of the my box
how dare are you taking the monitor to
say I'm jumping ahead and I place I
thought you say you put away the other
in the box come in stay there stay that
good I did not mean to do that while you
push it away and leave you do something
that yeah now I come here look at the
box so I made these I take adagietto and
jumper hot Oh Tommy
Pato put it here here hey high-five
[Music]
nice going girl that was really good hey
make me make me wanna go over a sure
thing how the hell did you shoot that
[Music]
[Laughter]
woman you crazy
you must become a URI really kalyanam I
can tell that well well well no we you
can add your law same time one Yolo
no dogs yalla no bueno
capiche a super Mario bohner whoa I said
no your Lord poured dosa oh yeah yeah uh
I
you call yourself italiano you
you know you're no give me you still
wanna shoot and play Call of Duty hola
alright okay do not jump okay we all at
the same time
now I you know although at the same time
you know y'all oh no you know well you
can just go back so it's fine yeah thank
you but you were so good the other time
you made yourself an italiana Romana and
I'm like what the hell yeah I'm moving
your body to help
that's what you did you in here earlier
we're getting that is now I got the
portal
yo no first try mother go mighty you
know inter yeah interviewed by the block
looking bada ba ba-ba boom Shakalaka
boom Shakalaka
you come here now okay
you see when it unlocks itself that's
when you go
[Music]
so yeah faster louder hey yay yay
what you gonna do girl I'm gonna click
down I swear I wanted to live away I
really like these
[Music]
I go I go I go I go I go I go BAM
chocolate Austria manikins
penis enlarger I don't know okay yeah
okay
okay so thank you so much for watching
and I see you next episode about
whatever he makes he will see you next
that's not a boy Bharathi
[Music]